you out of your mind here's the debate
you're upset they're saying We Believe
[Music]
all right episode 170 happy 7-Eleven day
today 7 11 July 11th yes it is there it
is and uh uh uh if we can turn that off
I think uh oh this is mine okay happy
7-Eleven day we have a special uh guest
here for you matter of fact when when he
walked into the building guys everybody
like held onto their laptops it was like
you have to see this thing because you
know in the history of mankind I think
we have to preface this properly if you
can set this up in a history of mankind
go won more than one I sent you the link
I sent you I don't know if you got it or
not there's been many special laptops
okay you zoom in This Is 40 Years of
history of laptops guys I mean with how
laptops change the world go down let's
go through the first one the first ever
laptop go a little lower little lower
it's a 1981 Osborne the world's first
truly mobile computer look at that
that's great I mean listen Max got
nothing on that look at that system
right they're just incredible floppy
disks right first laptop go to the next
one that's legendary then you got the
1983 grid Compass 1101 the first
clamshell laptop okay uh go to the next
one keep going keep going keep going
then we got the 1989 compact LTE compact
lt286 the first notebook PC I've seen
I've seen Adam with that one before I
think when he goes to Miami he takes
that one with them keep going keep going
keep going it is pretty sick then he got
the 1986 Macintosh portable the first
Apple laptop bam this is I think by the
team of wozniak's team I think I think
it was wozniak's team keep going keep
going keep going then we got the 1991
Apple power book 100 series of
revolutionary early laptop keep going
keep going keep going then we got the
1992 IBM Thinkpad 700 a powerful and
iconic laptop but none of these laptops
Tyler
have the kind of influence that the
other laptop if you want to put it up
this is the laptop of the century folks
and this laptop was brought to a shop by
today's guest John Paul Mac Isaac 10
minutes before he's about to close his
shop he's just like listen I want to go
home I want to relax I want to have I
don't know maybe he's a green tea type
of a person before I go to sleep and
then this man knocks on the door
he opens the door and he's going to tell
you the story who it was but the world
wants to learn about this laptop there's
about 95 channels that are not talking
about it there's only one channel and a
couple podcasts that are talking about
it and we said you know why don't we
reach out and bring them out to the
podcast so tell us a little bit about
this laptop so with that being said John
Park Paul Mack Isaac it's great to have
you on thanks for having me yes you know
yesterday we were having a podcast prep
meeting and Adam was concerned his
concern was if you were gonna wear that
hat or not because for Adam who's never
served before he he would like there's
like an ass in you know a little a
little bit of respect you have for you
know military all that stuff big time so
but anyways it's great to have you on
here for people that don't know if you
don't mind taking a minute giving
everybody your background and had the
story came about with Hunter Biden's
laptop
well uh it was Friday night about 10
minutes before closing and Hunter came
in with three liquid damage MacBooks and
I can tell you for a fact that was not
one of them hmm that is a photo probably
part of a disinformation operation but
we can go into that later uh he he
showed up one was by the way just out of
your arrested is the actual laptop's
picture anywhere online no
so you never took a picture of it no you
don't have a video of the laptop no I
have the serial number but you didn't
take any videos or anything with the
left I I wanted that thing out of my
shop no [ __ ] you know wow it was number
one priority was get it to the
authorities so I could have some level
of protection okay so go ahead I'm sorry
continue so uh he came in the 15-inch
MacBook Pro had a uh Beau Biden
Foundation sticker on it so I kind of
instantly assumed because his brother
had passed away I believe about a year
before that these were his deceased
Brothers laptops because a lot of
customers come in and they want to
recover their memories off of their
deceased loved ones devices so it is a
common thing and I felt bad for the guy
and even though I was trying to get out
of there I was like look I didn't you
know he's got three max I would normally
charge two hundred dollars a pop for
data recovery let me see the severity of
the failure so I helped them out one
machine was a complete write-off the
other machine just had missing or
inoperable keys from liquid damage so I
gave him a keyboard and I showed him how
to that's how I learned his password so
if there's any question on hacking
usually people that get hacked don't
voluntarily give away their passwords in
that process uh John Paul you're in
Delaware correct yep Wilmington okay so
that's Biden country so yeah I live
about 10 miles from okay and when he
walked in did you know exactly who he
was or guys I know you're visually
impaired where does that come into the
to play here I didn't know who I was
talking to until he presented the Beau
Biden thing and then when I was checking
him in at the actual check-in process I
asked him who he was and he was like
Hunter and then obviously you just knew
exactly who that was right there when he
sarcastically said it Biden when I
requested his last name because I think
he just automatically anticipated me
knowing who he was
um
I I then I was like all right and then
the Beau Biden sticker kind of put
everything together but again I never
really cared what he looked like or who
he was for that matter and this is in
2019 this is uh April 12 2019. got it
so I uh I give him back the one machine
the third machine uh had some power
issues wouldn't power on so I had to
take it in the back and check that one
in so I ultimately just created a bill
that said data recovery for three max
because again I hadn't gone through them
yet and 85 bucks which is the basically
the lowest rate that I could charge
somebody and because at again at that
time I thought I was helping this guy
who's inebriated he looked a mess and I
thought he was in grieving this is him
his deceased Brothers things so I didn't
discover until I started doing the data
recovery the following day that this was
not his deceased Brothers laptops these
were actually his
um and then I saw a lot of compromising
a lot of embarrassing material on the
laptop but again this was April 12th
there were 13 14 15. so this wasn't
his dad wasn't running for president yet
so and I never thought he would because
it was Joe he was kind of in in
declining years so uh I really didn't
get afraid until about a couple weeks
later when his father announced his
candidacy and I realized that there's
probably going to be a member on the
staff or a secret service member that's
going to find this piece of paperwork
authorizing me to recover data from
these three laptops and if they know
what's on those laptops then I'm the
only one on the planet that knows about
that behavior and I I thought my days
were numbered so I needed to
uh when it became my property uh in
about mid July of three years ago uh I I
knew that I needed to get it to the
authorities but I didn't trust local
authorities I didn't trust the FBI Roger
Stone was rated I think in January that
previous January so I had definitely
apprehensions about going to the FBI so
I went to the only person I really
trusted and that was my father and in
September of 2019 on a car ride back
from uh uh a gunship reunion in uh Utah
it was like a seven hour drive back to
Denver and Mom's asleep in the back so I
figured this is a good time to to
explain to my situation to my father and
and uh I told him everything and and not
everything he didn't want to know
certain things for plausible deniability
but we both agreed that the best thing
for him to do was get get him the
paperwork get him a copy of the drive so
he could approach the FBI out in
Albuquerque
and about this time my mom woke up and
she made the statement she goes that
sounds like the laptop from hell so
needless to say she's pretty upset with
Miranda Devine for uh stealing but
uh so on October 8th after I mailed my
father a copy of the drive and gave them
all the paperwork or copies of the
paperwork he went to the FBI uh field
office in Albuquerque
where an agent refused to give his name
uh kind of harassed my father uh
question motives questioned the legality
of my the possession of the device and
basically told him to lawyer up and get
out of the get out of the office and I
mean this is the first time my father's
career 31-year career colonel in the Air
Force uh never asked anything from
the you know the bureaucracy basically
and so he was a bit disappointed that
you know all he wanted was protection
for his son so about a month later
apparently he got the attention to
someone because the FBI reached out to
him in an effort to get a hold of me uh
we agreed and the FBI came to my house I
explained the situation in about
beginning of November and yeah about
mid-november
and I presented them with some stuff I
had printed up because during this time
the impeachment hearings had started or
there was Whispers of it it was it was
getting close there was now the big
concern sure I'm fearful of my safety
I've definitely witnessed criminal
activity on this device
uh but now there's an impeachment that's
Whispers of impeachment that's occurring
over a phone call about the previous
administration in Ukraine and I had seen
enough information on that laptop to
know that there was a blatant pay for
play scheme the Biden's made out like
Bandits during the 2014 Ukrainian
conflict and in my opinion from what I
had seen president Trump had every
reason to call zelinski considering
zielinski was created by Igor kolamoisky
who was Hunter by his business partner
and when when the bidens could no longer
protect kolamoisky and his billions that
he embezzled during the Ukraine conflict
uh colemanski did the next best thing he
made his own president he took his prize
actor from his TV
um series and or TV station and groomed
him to be the president got him elected
so now he doesn't have to worry first
thing zelinski did when he got elected
was uh the the privatization of uh
profitabank which was Igor's Bank he
made that illegal so he could have his
bank back have his money back and return
to the country so it was
to and to watch what's happening in
Ukraine happen all over again it's it's
scary except this time we're sending
40 billion instead of 18 billion uh John
what would you say if I mean if you can
even say it besides the you know the
Ukraine and all that type of so what was
the most disturbing thing that you saw
that you I don't know if you told
anybody but what was there anything that
would make you go like oh my God like
you should be in prison for this 100
percent
um
yeah I I think I know where you're
getting that yeah uh and and there has
been a lot of efforts by a lot of
individuals out there to
uh
metaphorically or not literally insert
fake data onto this laptop and there's a
couple reasons why somebody would want
to do this they either want to get
notoriety and fame for something that
they have zero involvement in
or
there's an effort to insert questionable
material into a laptop that's in the
possession of members of Congress so if
you wanted to punish certain members of
Congress then you have an excuse to say
especially if they received into copies
of a drive that has this alleged
material from an individual that may
have put this in material on it and the
other concern that we should be careful
like Hunter signed a document after 90
days that laptop became my property
if there's another laptop out there that
has 450 gigs of mysteriously discovered
80 000 images of this or whatever
that came from something else that was
not legally acquired so if you start to
muddy the waters and then we're expected
to have something that's going to be
admitted as evidence and and hopefully
trials that'll occur in the next couple
years we can't have that information be
tainted and we can't have somebody throw
it all out because somebody decided to
run an operation to lie about the
contents of the data so we have to be
really careful I didn't see any CP in
the levels that people are talking I saw
a lot of inappropriate behavior with
family members and and that's all I'm
going to talk about wow inappropriate
behavior with family members
okay let me speculate let me I'm gonna
speculate you you know
you can decide to say whatever you want
to say speculative
inappropriate content with family
members
so it would be drugs it would be sex it
would be theft
it would be uh accounts it would be what
else it would be I mean that's what it's
going to be outside of that what else
would be in there right again like I've
always known people there's enough
criminal material on that laptop we
don't need to make up anything we don't
need to find a dark place in our minds
where we want to believe that there's
this evil that's on it that's there's
enough evil on it we don't need to make
up who has the laptops now well the FBI
should they took it from me uh gave me a
subpoena and everything and a receipt
and uh that was December 9th 2019 uh if
they've lost it I I have a cot I still
have the copy that I gave my Father
which predates the copy I gave to Rudy
or Rudy's office because I never gave it
to Rudy did you sign off that you can
never talk about what's in the laptop
did you say that to the FBI or no the
only thing I remotely said to the FBI
and like that was jokingly when they
were leaving yeah I said don't don't
worry Lads when I write the book I'll
leave your names out yeah and that's
when one agent turned around and said in
our experience nothing ever happens to
people that don't talk about these
things
so you so you and I was like all right
I'm going to be quiet so you've never
told anything to anybody about the
laptop
well not until I reached out directly to
uh Rudy giuliani's office I so
when the FBI took possession of
everything my fingers were crossed
because I was hoping even though a lot
of red flags occurred they told me that
if anybody or Hunter came looking for it
I was to give them a BS story that it's
off-site and give me a couple days to
get it I was immediately to text agent
Mike and he would return the laptop to
me so I'm thinking if this is evidence
how can they return it and that's kind
of
where I started to feel like they cared
more about the owner of the previous
owner of the laptop and protecting them
that they did about protecting me so and
of course when the impeachment happened
and this laptop was nowhere to be seen
and it was admitted as evidence for the
defense from the White House then I was
just like okay we need to go to another
level here so I sent my father and my
uncle who's also a retired colonel in
the Air Force to I gave them enough
material basically the material I had
printed up and given to the tried to
give to the FBI but they didn't touch it
they just gave me a subpoena wanted all
his stuff and then left
um
so they went out knocked on members of
Congress
their doors to get their attention alert
them I even believe my uncle Ronson the
facts to the White House directly saying
we have National concern National
Security concerns because not only for a
pay for play but just the amount of
sensitive data that was being sent in
the open unencrypted to private
Ukrainian citizens and this information
included everything from the vice
president's travel schedule all policies
and procedures economics any discussion
that the White House would have relating
to Ukraine was being sent to a private
Ukrainian citizen that worked for a
company that was employing the vice
president's son
and that is not cool so John Paul you it
sounds like not only were you fixing the
laptop you were getting in there I mean
you were looking at there was and this
isn't I don't think hearsay there was
pornography on there there's a lot okay
boom there's definitely some smoke and
crack stuff going on a lot boom
um but then there's this Ukrainian
business dealing stuff sounds like you
went pretty deep into those emails yeah
absolutely when when it became my
property and I'm thinking somebody's
going to kick down my door I'm I'm
waiting for it to happen I'm I'm trying
desperately I called him up multiple
times through the month of April and May
to come and pick up this you called
Hunter you're saying and no answer no
messages no nothing no text zero
response didn't come back I sent them
automated Square payment requests so he
was you know here 80 you owe the
matchbox 85 bucks well there was no
response whatsoever well he responded so
when I called him up I want to say it
was like the 15th yeah when I was done
with the recovery it's like the
following Monday called him up to let
him know hey you know I recovered about
220 gigabytes of data uh go to Best Buy
if you get a drive that's you know 500
gigs or bigger that'll be more than
enough uh drop it off give me 24 hours
and then I'll knock it out so he shows
up on the 16th and drops off the drive
so I know he's getting my messages I
know he's so he did come back he came
back and dropped off dropped off hard
drive a two terabyte Western Digital uh
external drive okay so you know if he
has any doubt where where he was uh on
that weekend I can say that he was at a
Best Buy and his credit card
but then he never came back to pick up
yeah that's when he asked me to Bill him
electronically I said his Square okay
he's like sure and then he never came
back in
so if you've got multiple dealings with
Hunter Biden the first time that he
showed up first time and then the second
time when he came to drop off the the
drive and then after he dropped off the
drive zero response after that zero
except until his lawyer uh called me up
on October 13 2020 the day before the uh
New York Post ran the story so the eve
of that uh he called me up because I
guess it's common practice for when your
story is going to go you want to reach
out to those involved see if they have a
statement so he calls me up about 10
minutes before closing on that Tuesday
and uh it was like yeah my client left a
laptop with you he said 2017 so I was
like well Hunter doesn't remember
2019 but I'll go with it so I kind of I
did what the FBI told me to do I said
um hey normally we don't hold on to
equipment that long but I'll check in
our reclamation center tomorrow and uh
can you shoot me an email with your
credentials and and so I know that you
can represent officially represent the
client and he agreed so I have an email
saying hey I'm Hunter's lawyer thanks
for talking to me tonight so I was like
well that's good enough for me and then
I I immediately called Bob Costello who
was my point of contact at Rudy
giuliani's office and I'm and he was
also
promise me that if anything ever hit the
fan I was to call him and he'd take care
of my security needs so I call him up
and I'm like I think it hit the fan I
just got a call from uh George maceras
who's Hunter's lawyer and he was like uh
that ship sound go go and get some sleep
nothing could be done it's uh and the
story's coming out tomorrow and I'm like
okay great the fact that uh George
messeris asked me on the phone he said
are you still at the backside of Trolley
Square and that was like enough for me
not to go home that night because I
figured he knew he knew exactly where I
was and so and the story hadn't broken
yet I figured once the story was out
then I would be okay because then I
wouldn't be murdered so
um unfortunately watching the next day
uh watching the
the internet and mainstream media put a
kibosh on on the whole story and prevent
the truth from getting out and then the
narrative is being replaced that I you
know colluded with a foreign power to
affect an election
so that uh things start to go downhill
rather quickly after that so you would
say John that there's definitely
impeachable stuff on the on those
laptops to get uh Joe Biden's compromise
and his son should be in jail
I I
would rather us find the heart and and
Joe's cabinet to do the 25th amendment I
just don't like impeachment I did not
want Trump to get impeached not because
I'm a trump fan but because impeachment
when it starts to be wielded as a tool
for a political party to just punish the
guy because they don't like him as
opposed to the tool that it's meant to
be you know that's dangerous I mean
there's a reason why we've only had
three impeachments and what was
something meant that was never supposed
to be used they weren't ever supposed to
use impedance yeah it's like break glass
in case of emergency right and I didn't
like when I was young and I saw what
happened to Clinton and I'm like well
you know I get it but here's the part
here's a part with impeachment uh Bill
did what he did fine okay and Peter
Clinton is what I'm talking about set
that aside what they claimed would Trump
for what Russia never came out right
that's great but set that aside uh every
president at some point they talk about
impeaching them the other party talks
about impeachment it's like a couple
words that people like to use you know
they like to use the name from the guy
that was in Germany who you know World
War II hey that's years like Hitler
Tendencies and then you'd like to use
impeached but let's let's set that one
to the part that that I want to know few
I want to know a few things from urine
and then I want to know some things
about the whole situation so number one
is there anything in the laptop you saw
that you've never told anybody
there's a couple things
and why haven't you told anybody
well
I've never thought it was my
responsibility to tell anybody other
than the authorities
okay it's it's
and I and I get it I never wanted to go
to the media I never wanted to go to the
press and I
and I know why and that's because I knew
the media would focus on the the sex and
the drugs and the and not the the con
the the wholesale of our state
department for personal gain or the
National Security concerns or the
embarrassment that we will endure when
all this comes out it's that it
I saw criminal activity I needed to get
this to the proper authorities the
property authorities bailed so I went to
members of congress not directly my
uncle and then when that didn't get any
traction I came out from the Shadows
because I was again scared I didn't want
to lose my business I didn't want to be
a Chase from my home I didn't want I
wanted to have nobody know I existed
but I wanted the truth to get out and
then I realized the only way that was
going to happen is if I knocked on the
door of the a lawyer for the president
of the United States and that worked
and when you say members of Congress I
don't need names but did you go to
Republican Democrat you're in Delaware
who'd you go to we uh my uncle and my
father only approached members of
Congress that were conservatives uh okay
for obvious reasons so you went to
Republicans and you got rebuffed they
had no love for what you had to say what
happened so and I I've had discussions
with some of these individuals that were
presented with this information and I
get it during the we're talking about
February through June July of 2020. so
there was a pandemic going on there was
also we're coming off the the heels of
Russia three years of Russia Russia
Russia everybody is so paranoid of being
caught up in another uh conspiracy uh
jeopardizing the political embarrassment
uh and and and they have a good reason
because look at what happened with
things like Dominion you know the
conspiracy goes out there oh Dominion's
changing changing all these votes around
and then they prove it's wrong now
Dominion gets to file a 16.7 million
dollar billion dollar lawsuit and go
after all the people that got hooked
into this disinformation these
disinformation ploys and that's why I
warned Congress again when there was an
individual out in Switzerland trying to
say he's found 400 and he's given these
drives we saw uh who's that the young
guy he was parade around Congress going
I have uh I have a copy of the drive he
was on C-Span forgot the name of the guy
yeah a young kid so no Republicans were
even willing to listen to yourself the
paterical guard intercepted my uncle and
my father and and never let them get
past the door so let me go back let me
go back to the question so I want to
stay focused on this so there's a couple
things you said that no one knows about
that's only you that you've kept to
yourself are those couple things like
tremendously bigger than what the public
has already been rumored that was in the
laptop or no it's just a couple things
you just kept away from everybody well
again I never felt like it was my
responsibility to share that no but
that's not what I'm asking what I'm
asking is those 10 things that you've
kept to yourself are they much bigger
and heavier stuff than all the other
things
[Music]
personally yes okay but but for the
country and for the purpose of why I
gave it to laptop no it's it's more of I
I through Hunter's Behavior I should
have a fear for my life okay so it's
more
more speculation Hunter with a minor
than it is about linked to the president
than what he did with Ukraine or deal
side deals right it's more personal link
200 not linked to the father it's linked
to Hunter okay perfect so let's set that
aside that's you know Hunter's dealing
that he's he's got to go deal with okay
so that those two things the couple
things that you haven't told anybody
have you told that to the person you
trust the most which is your father
does anybody knows it just you you're
the only person no people I trust me
okay so what I would say to you is I
probably wouldn't hang on to that
because if you do you're not protected
you know and I'm not I don't know if you
understand what I'm saying because if
you if you're sitting on I was like you
know all of a sudden let's put them on
suicide watch that's kind of how people
get put on suicide watches oh I had to
make that video a long time ago yeah
well you did make that video oh yeah
what he's basically asking you about
well no so no you don't need Secrets
yeah yeah like like I'm I'm if I show up
exactly yeah I'm not gonna kill him like
a John McAfee I am never going to commit
suicide just so you guys know in jail
yeah you don't get into heaven right
yeah yeah exactly yeah
so a couple things that you haven't told
anybody so okay so the stuff that's
linked on the other side see for me when
it comes down to this here's how I see
this and and you know commentary from
your end so at this point in the game
everybody knows the media held that
story back they didn't want it to go up
Twitter you know prevented it Facebook
prevent everybody knows that to the
point where even Bill Maher called out
Twitter and everybody else to not tell
that story and we knew that was going to
affect the election everybody knew that
but they kept it away that that story
was going viral on Twitter in the first
30 minutes whatever it was boom taken
down but even Bill Maher who were big
fans of Bill Maher comes out and says
what the hell are you doing and even a
Jon Stewart interview and Bob Iger says
what the hell is going on with media
that nobody trusts him right okay so you
got two guys by the way I I feel I'm not
a guy that supports Biden's style of
leadership but for a father as a father
you don't want to see your son go
through that it's painful I can see that
being very very painful for the family
okay from the uh Biden side so whatever
Hunter has done you know you're gonna
have kids sometimes your kids are going
to do stuff that's going to be
embarrassing and that's not you know
your responsibility that that kid is
going to be held responsible based on
the laws and the guidelines that the
states offer in the federal offers he's
going to be held accountable to that if
they pursue him right but stuff that he
did
that has to do with the rest of the
people that has to do with the voters
and the people he leads that's a
different story when everybody kept
saying Russia Russia Russia you know
what happened to a lot of Republicans
behind closers and independents you know
what people said maybe this is true and
if it's true man what are you doing
selling out America to Russia I'm not
okay for that you know even even
conservative if this is true let me tell
you I'm not with it I'm not I know a lot
of people that said I'm not with it if
this is true and it wasn't true but this
is true people are seeing it and no
one's talking about it this is when
hypocrisy hurts these guys right here
when you look at this article saying you
failed Bill Maher blast Twitter for
censoring post after bombshell uh report
on Hunter Biden's laptop so I just went
on Twitter right now can you go on
Google right now and type in Hunter
Biden laptop go on Google and type in
Hunter Biden laptop okay
and zoom in a little bit so we can all
see it zoom in zoom and zoom in so go
and click on news go and click on news
yeah news zoom in a little bit more so
New York Post center right Yahoo uh is
just only covering what he said to his
mom which I think he called her a
spoiled uh the c word right I think yeah
okay next is what Washington Times
center right keep going lower New York
Post Fox News Fox News right uh Gazette
okay so he so then go on YouTube go on
YouTube and just go straight up on
YouTube yeah and type in type in um type
in uh go on CNN YouTube channel just go
on CNN okay just go to their Channel
click on CNN right there go to videos go
to videos okay now go sort by recent so
go up go zoom in a little bit so the
rest of us can see not popular let's
find the way it is so zoom in the rest
of us can see let's look at titles okay
here's what January 6 okay man who said
he was almost a school shooter okay
what's the next title something about
Tucker pregnant woman claims uh what's
he talking about the west side west
risks failure in Ukraine keep going up
okay Steve bannon's coming up January 6
protesters GOP Governor comedians talk
about pranking okay NASA uh Republican
voter rejects GOP protester storm uh
presidential whatever Elon Musk may be
on the hook soldiers this that's how far
back now two days January 6th I'm at
three days now uh this low okay so then
type in honorable okay nothing with Chan
coming out saying okay type in Hunter
Biden laptop
okay
go hunter Biden laptop okay so Hunter
Biden reveals new detail on 100 right
investigation three months ago 100 by
under investigation one year ago
Trump pushing for special counsel a year
ago
stelter this was Fox News biggest story
last week a year ago
U.S investigation okay now here's what I
want you to do go up and type in January
6th in the second in the same party put
in put January 6th okay uh okay so how
many go two days ago two days ago three
days ago two days ago keep going 22
hours ago three days ago five days ago
10 they hate Mr Jam alone if you're
watching this you say you want to take
CNN back to Ted Turner days why don't
you go read his book
and see the last interview he does on
how disappointed he is with CNN this is
exactly why this is why when you claim
can you put Jamal's quote that he put up
go to the article that he put up this is
the guy that apparently is who is the
new guy from Discovery that uh he's not
the CEO because they brought a different
guy that's a CEO I think he's the owner
of CNN if I'm not the article I sent you
uh uh uh yeah so go to whatever the
article is CNBC this the one okay make
it a little bigger so we can all see it
John Lewis has won a media Discovery
getting rid of CNN would be the coward
coward's way out okay keep going up
let's read that one legendary quote he
has in here which I love uh right there
in the middle zoom in so everybody can
see it there's a place for CNN's 43
billion dollar combination of Warner
media and Discovery billionaire Mogul uh
uh John Malone told CNBC in a recorded
an interview that air Thursday I would
like to see CNN evolve back to the kind
of Journalism that it started with and
actually have journalists which would be
unique and refreshing uh he told TV TV
Pioneer long-time chairman of Liberty
Media which is a major shareholder in
Discovery I do believe good journalism
could have a role in the future
portfolio of Discovery and Time Warner
going to president golden Lord to read
the next part on what he says go a
little lower a cowards what way out
would be to sell CNN or spin it off and
sell it right and then he's obviously
talking about that we should go back to
how journalism was well John you ain't
doing it just so you know you are not
doing it the American and by the way
we're not journalists here we're
podcasters
this is a YouTube channel none of us
went to Colombia to be journalists did
you go to Columbia to be journalists no
sir Tyler did you go to Columbia to be
journalists yes you went to Columbia to
be a journalist nope say it because some
people are watching it seriously did you
go to Columbia or no no none of us went
to journalism school I'm a military guy
I got it I went into business he was a
comedian he went into insurance he got
into he's a comedian that's what he does
he was on Def Comedy Jam funny guy CNN
CNBC MSNBC do your job we are not
journalists do your job we want to find
out what is going on here you're losing
credibility by not covering the story
that needs to be told rather you only
cover in January 6th because you're
afraid of the guy that could potentially
go run for office and that guy that
could potentially go run for office
what's his name um
Donald J Trump who is right now the
Republican candidate your fear is God
forbid if that guy gets elected if we
tell the story we're going to lose Biden
here's the reality of it CNN what do you
tell the story or not here's what you
have to stop worrying about Joe Biden
and getting and getting reelected
so so what are you going to do hurt his
campaign he's not running again
you can actually do what you did to
promo and actually do some journalism
and tell us what happened with Cuomo
good you told us we wanted to know we
appreciate you being transparent about
that part eventually took a while
because some people have to oust it with
what happened with Chris Cuomo then
Zucker gets fired and Chris Cuomo gets
fired Andrew Cuomo gets right and it's
all a [ __ ] show for CNN that you guys
went through hey if you know Biden's not
going to get reelected why don't you
cover this story you're already building
up uh Newsome anyways why don't you tell
the story once you tell the rest of us
what's really going on there are certain
things we have access to we don't have
40 people that their job is to go to
investigative reporting we don't do that
yet that's not our job that's your job
you do that professionally can you be a
professional and fulfill Ted Turner's
book and a vision that he had matter of
fact why don't you call CNN's book of
the month
first book you guys all read is Ted
Turner's book can you put up Ted
Turner's book on what it was they called
me Ted or something like that if you
work at CNN whether you support the
organization or not why don't you go
read this book go listen to the
audiobook and see how finishes the book
at the end every employee at CNN needs
to read this book that came out 13 years
ago everyone I'd love to interview him
every time we ask him unfortunately he's
not doing too well we do anything to be
able to interview him right now we would
do anything to be able to talk to him
because he was a Visionary that started
this he did he's the guy that did what
TNT was a TNT TBS Atlanta Falcons
Atlanta Hawks Atlanta all this stuff we
everybody in the nation became Dominic
Wilkins fans because of Ted Turner
everybody was following the oh oh what
you know Justice with Terry Pendleton
with you know Kenny Lofton with you know
the pitchers Millwood glavin
we all became Braves fans because of
this guy
tell us the truth what is going on here
stop playing damn politics do your job
we're all relying on you to do your job
this applies to everybody and the only
reason I'm specifically singling out CNN
is because John Malone had the audacity
to come out and say something like he's
just said right now saying hey we got to
go back to journalism great right we're
going to hold you to it we'd like to see
what's going on so how many of these
guys have reached out how many times has
CNN reached out well how many times has
Don Lemon reached out how many times has
uh uh
MSNBC reached out how many times has CBS
reached out how many times has ABC
reached that for anything how many times
have you seen an email saying we would
like to come have you on the show well
let me let me say on October 14th when I
I was outed so uh the New York Post in
an accident when they had a copy of
hunters signed authorization it they
forgot to blur out the Mac shop name so
people were able to Google the Mac shop
figure out who I was and the attacks
start started instantly and so did the
media tax I had five reporters work
their way through a customer that was
trying to leave the shop because I had
the doors locked for coveted
restrictions and just keep people out
and uh so they pursed in and then I
didn't know that I was being recorded
and they kind of cornered me
um and secretly recorded me and then
that got out and then I realized oh my
God I'm not built for this at all and
that was my first experience with the
press and they they tore me to pieces I
I talked to Bob Costello that evening he
gave me some pointers and
the next day I felt a little bit more
confident and when I came back from
lunch break so this was October 15th I
had CNN Washington Post and New York
Times
in front of my shop and I was like all
right I'm ready for this I'm going to
just do what Bob told me to do tell just
tell him what I told the FBI because I
can't get in any any trouble if my story
which is the truth is the same story
that I told the FBI you know a year
almost a year at this time prior and uh
so I did I told him everything and they
didn't publish a word of it it's like
they were never there and then the
Washington Post reached out and that's I
wanted to bring this up the CNN article
from three months ago what else happened
three months ago the Washington Post
admitted that the laptop was real and
the New York Times admitted that the
laptop was real so CNN came out with
that little tiny they snuck it in I
watched it happen it was like late at
night they just put out this little
little article acknowledging that the
laptop was real and that was just to
cover their bum you know that this
doesn't work this business model doesn't
work so so there's two stories here
we're going to go back to what some of
the things to get a little bit deeper
but this business model doesn't work
people are not dumb you're not going to
win like this CNN just so you know
people know you're playing games and
they don't like it tell the story tell
us what happened tell us really what's
going on over here and then let us make
a decision if it's real or not and it
will go from there but the business
model they're taking is not going to be
an effective business model long term if
you sell insurance you sell insurance
you can't say well we're only going to
sell insurance to such and such people
if you if you if you do real estate you
have to do real estate if you don't real
estate the Market's not going to favor
you if you do media journalism you call
yourself a journalist well then go do
some investigative journalism and do
some digging or podcasters
we're just regular guys that want to see
what's going on in the world because
we're concerned about the future
um
anyways for me it's more about the
accountability than anything else so
since then that this has taken place uh
have you has your business been affected
are people still coming to your business
have you shut down the business what's
going are you still living in Delaware
have you moved to Alaska what how's
personal life going uh so initially the
media did a great job of blocking the
story so I had customers coming in but
the people that had heard so customers
would come in and they'd say why is
there dog [ __ ] in front of your shop or
why is there a tomato smashed on the
sidewalk or what's that sign mean and I
just was kind of Lucky at that point
because I knew bulk and my customers
were liberal and like most of the city
and that if they didn't know what I had
done then then I was okay but
unfortunately that the words started
getting out plus the amount of people
that were coming into the shop without
computers
were starting to make me nervous because
to the point where I had to fill out a
domestic terroristic threat Report with
Wilmington Police Department I do want
to say that I'm grateful for the
Wilmington PD they put somebody in front
of my shop every time I was there for
like about the three weeks that I
remained open until I I had to close
because I just it was getting too
dangerous
um
you know when you start to get death
threats and the area codes are LA or San
Diego or Seattle you don't you don't
care it's a free country people can rage
and and lash out whatever cat's out of
the bag I mean be a be a punching bag
for these people gets it off their chest
whatever
but when the area code started to be an
856 and 484 that's across the river in
Jersey that's you know 15 minutes down
the 202 into Pennsylvania that's when it
started to get a little scary and then
then there were some interactions with
some people that were not coming to my
shop for service they were coming to do
me harm so it was it was time for me to
close up the shop I closed the shop up
on November 2nd I didn't go home I was
kind of told by an individual that was
helping me that worked with my father my
father worked briefly at the CIA
and he said that that the Threat Level
was getting really high and regardless
of the direction that the election was
going to take though he was confident
that the election was was in the hands
of Biden already that I needed to get
out of town because there's a
probability that my name's next to a
check box that's waiting to be checked
off and
and I just it's not safe so I left I
went into hiding bounced around mostly
in Colorado uh
when things started to settle down I
actually uh went to woodworking school
at a local community college everybody
out there was wearing masks so I figured
nobody knew who I was and and probably
nobody would I tried to start a Mac
business but within the first hour that
I put up a Facebook page somebody was
like don't trust this guy he'll steal
your data so you know that didn't last
you went to the school did you wear the
hat or no no I I have another hat I just
I can't wear that because that's a
iconic if you wear that they're going to
know who you are yeah you know when when
the when the hate mail started coming in
and there was a common theme yeah Putin
thanks you for your service and Russia
loves you or I hope your business fails
but you'll uh Donnie will pay for your
your your you know pardon you or
whatever and but the the Common Thread
started your hat is ugly or your hat is
stupid so I figured well UC Berkeley had
with a mask nobody would bother it I
figure but I figure if they care more
about the Hat than they do about the
truth then I don't need to engage with
them there's that's a pointless
conversation anyway and then I started
to realize that they really hate this
hat
and that their tears Give me fuel so you
know there's what's a lot of what's kept
me going like to want to continue to
fight because when you get for me it's
if I feel boxed in a corner and any
animal that's in the corner is going to
lash out so I don't understand why they
they keep coming after me they they
tried to withhold my unemployment uh the
IRS dinged me for 57 from like seven
years ago six years ago it's like
they're they're doing these little
things here and there that to mess with
me and it's like all this is going to do
is make me want to fight harder and now
that I have really nothing left to lose
then why not see it to the end so I'm
going to try to do everything I can to
hold these guys accountable not just the
the people
not just the mainstream and social media
though I tried to go after Twitter and
uh everything was looking really good
for a while and then they switched
judges on me with an Obama appointed
judge because to prove that I wasn't a
hacker we were going to have to have
Hunter come in and explain that that was
his signature that was him so we were
going to have Hunter testify and then I
guess the White House didn't like that
so they switched judges on me and the
judge threw the case out awarded Twitter
uh the Florida slap statue so then I was
in the hole with Twitter for 175 000 so
whatever elon's doing right now if he's
gonna make that thing Crash and Burn God
bless him I'm I'm it's the closest I've
seen the Justice whatever he's doing to
Twitter is as close as I've seen the
Justice you've got some you've got some
beef with Twitter that I'm not
speculating you've come out and said
that your biggest beef might be with
Twitter I think you were trying to sue
some of these media Outlets but
Twitter's at the top of your list well
Twitter Twitter I tried to sue because
they labeled me a hacker and they said
that their their reasoning for blocking
the story from every form of
communication was that it was based on
hacked material I'm not a hacker so I
went because Hunter gave you the laptop
he gave me permission my job was to
recover I didn't I wasn't there to fix a
laptop it was to recover the data and
then after 90 days illegally it became
yours because he signed a a bill or an
invoice saying hey after 90 days if you
don't pay this is now my property and
and there's no expectation of privacy
when it comes to things you abandoned so
I never felt like I ever did anything
wrong so to get labeled a hacker because
people are like you're gonna rot in
prison for hacking I'm like I didn't
hack anything so if I'm ever going to
start a business again fixing computers
having people late if I don't clear my
name in the court of law that I'm not a
hacker I'm never going to have a
successful business again so that's why
I went after Twitter
again and we beat 230 Twitter put up the
230 protection defense yeah and we
actually beat them which I think is a
first my lawyer we were high-fiving it
was it was a good time things looked
very optimistic and then about June they
switched the judges and then the judge
uh demanded that my lawyer go down to
Florida to explain to her why this case
shouldn't be thrown out so that was a
not a good sign and then it was thrown
out and then I was Twitter I have to pay
Twitter's legal fees so can I read a
quote that you said to the New York Post
maybe we'll put up a discussion because
this has to do with Section 230 media I
believe you called the media these days
or at least big Tech state-run media so
this I I guess this is according to the
post after fighting to reveal the truth
all I want is for the rest of the
country to know that there was a
collective and orchestrated effort
by social and mainstream media to block
a real story with real consequences for
the nation
is that how you still feel things
absolutely that's that's why I'm I'm
suing right now with the help of the
America project uh I I to be honest I
thought I had to move back to Delaware
because I thought I would have to file
for bankruptcy and I had to be in my
house or I'd lose my house so I had to
leave where I was safe and go back to
now 10 miles from Joe Biden's house and
because I don't want to lose my house
so you know
you feel safe for being closer to Joe
Biden's house no I feel well I still I
feel safe in my house now yeah that's my
home and I'll like I don't know if I
don't know if Joe feels safer on Joe so
it's like and where does the Twitter
lawsuit stand right now with you oh no
they threw it out with prejudice and
then I I owe Twitter 175 000 and do you
plan on paying that or how's that well
it's mostly taken care of gotcha I mean
you're the second most famous person
that sweaters at Twitter is currently
suing well I'm pretty sure they well I I
don't think I'd I'd want to be famous
for that but uh now Twitter Twitter was
a realization I never thought I would
have my opportunity to hold these people
accountable in the court of law so I
wrote a book about because I thought
maybe Court of public opinion if I tell
my story and I put it in a book then the
mainstream media and social media can't
block it it'll be something that's
tactile in people's hands so I I didn't
think I'd have an opportunity again to
try to hold these people accountable uh
when you look at the the collusion so uh
Zuckerberg on I think October 25th 2020
emitted before Congress that the FBI
approached Facebook Twitter and Google
to warn them of a massive document dump
of
uh uh disinformation from a foreign
power okay he said that
and if it was at the end of the summer
all right I I mailed overnight a copy of
the drive to Bob costeller's office and
on August 28th so if the following week
the FBI is warning social media Outlets
to be on the lookout for a document dump
it makes it begs the question who who
has the fisa court for that was I being
monitored or was a lawyer for the
president of the United States being
monitored so I want to figure out who
gave the marching orders who told
everybody that this is Russian collusion
sure I want to clear my name obviously I
I don't want the Mac Isaac name which is
a pretty good name as far as the
military and love a country I don't need
to have Trader attached to that moving
forward and I'm not going to let them
take the narrative that they want to
push and allow that to end up in the
history books so there's yeah that's my
personal fight but the bigger picture is
is there was a colluded effort there was
collusion between mainstream and social
media and federal agencies at least we
know of the doj and the FBI's
involvement to keep this quiet
and we live in a country that we're
afraid of we're leaning towards
socialism we're like we're like halfway
there with our state-run media it's not
fair and it's not right and it shouldn't
happen to the country and it's
unfortunate that happened to me but the
biggest thing is is we should with 86
percent of Americans getting their news
through digital devices to have a lens
or a filter over that that's presented
to us that's controlled by a political
party
that's that's not right John Paul how
many people have you from former FBI
agents who maybe are conservative have
you spoken to how many of them have you
spoken to or they've reached out
uh I have talked to just in passing some
retired uh no not just the past no
nobody's reached out why not though why
not
I think uh I think by the way they think
I pulled a fast one on them when they
when I made a copy of the drive
I just thought they knew I had a copy of
the drive because my dad tried to give
him a copy of the drive back in October
of 2019. so I I was in giuliani's place
a week I don't know what it was maybe a
week or two after he they came into his
house and took everything that he had of
the Joe Biden stuff that he had and we
we did a five hour interview so three
and a half hours is not actually Mafia
states of america.com and I would say
half of the interview is about Joe Biden
and this was how long ago was this was
this like six months ago 12 months ago
came out in November eight months ago
right no way closer to a year probably a
year ago if you've not seen it folks you
got to go watch it in some obvious it's
uh of america.com the whole three and a
half hour interview with Joe with uh
what do you call it Rudy giuliani's
there and
obviously they went after Rudy to try to
get everything away taken away from him
for him to lose credibility but I I
wonder how come conservative influencers
from the FBI side how come they've not
reached out how come they've not reached
out to support well I think that I mean
up until the Washington Post and the New
York Times admitted that the laptop was
real I mean I had a book written it was
done in September of last year yeah and
I was spent three four five months
trying to get in contact with Publishers
anybody who would be interested in this
story and I got zero response from
anybody so it felt like my uncle and my
father got into Congress all over again
just nobody wants to touch this thing
with a 10-foot pole I believe because I
think they'd they have been
so who then who is liberatio protocol
who are they who's that publisher uh or
is it a conservative publisher uh that's
uh the offshoot from Post Hill uh postal
is my publisher Anthony's a car uh
really okay interesting so yeah he's got
some uh he's got some brass by the way
yeah he's he's he seems pretty yeah him
and I had a nice call three weeks ago I
like him a lot we had like a very
friendly call and he's a 15 years of
Simon and Schuster I mean you know so if
there's a guy that's got the audacity to
pick it up is that but here's what I
will tell you hey Republicans and
whoever you are on that side that you
are like complaining about this deal
that you have served in the FBI or CIA
or military or your general all that
stuff why are you not investigating and
finding out for yourself as well why
aren't you doing something about it okay
a retweet or a tweet is not enough we
don't do this for a living we're a
podcaster we just sit down and we have
these conversations why aren't some of
you guys that are connected to the FBI
are former fbis wants you guys reaching
out once you have in those kinds of
meetings it surprises me that that
that's that doesn't happen it surprised
me that some of them from their own Camp
are not reaching out to have these
conversations with you what are they
afraid of what happened is it a backbone
issue oh my God if I talk to him God
forbid something's gonna happen to my
career yeah no this look if if if your
concern is truly socialism
and everybody is waiting for the next
guy to pick up the fight then you're all
pansies
if your fear is really socialism and you
claim it as socialism I'm not talking
about you I'm talking about people who
claim Their Fear of socialism
why don't you do something about it why
don't you expose all the other stuff
because flip this real quick and flip it
real quick do you remember when Obama's
daughter got caught smoking weed at 13
years old
yeah do you remember what Obama said
what
Obama said you know
I the struggles of being a teenager I
remember I went through it myself as
well you know as a family we love her
and we're going to get through this and
papa you know what we said as an
audience what do we say okay okay cool
you know what cool cool moved on yeah
when Bill Clinton I did not have you
know yeah relations with that woman yeah
Miss Lewinsky yeah yeah are they quoting
Chappelle right anyway so and then what
happened you're like dude no it's fine
yeah we don't say our son should be like
you when they grow up although he
inspired a lot of people half the
country didn't care the other half
really really cared about the BJ I don't
care about McDougall I don't care about
uh
stormy I don't care about any of that
stuff listen if if you and by the way
the whole role model situation yeah
there's an element of a president being
a role model I totally agree there's an
element of the governors being a role
model I get that but I want to make sure
you got good policies to get good
results this is why when people say how
can you with Trump I like his policies
that's that's all it is I like his
policies his policies were very
effective for business it was a lot less
peace it was a lot more peaceful until
kova took place so in but even if you go
back to Reagan
imagine you have a son and you name your
son after you okay and you name him
Ronald Reagan and guess what the kid you
named after you hates your policies do
you know that story do you know Ronald
Reagan Jr completely disagrees with his
father you know what did media do he's
an atheist now he's he's you know but
but guess what guess what American
people said look everybody has issues
with their kids sometimes you have it
sometimes some kids want to do this hey
no problem we understand it hey why
aren't you wanting to cover the story
here but Pat can I post a uh maybe an
opposing view there is a difference
between the actual man the president and
what they do like you brought up
McDougall Trump Stormy Daniels Trump
Clinton Monica Lewinsky Right Reagan
he's allegedly had affairs on Nancy
versus the kids like you brought up one
of the Obama daughters smoking weed or
even hunt or smoking crack or even stuff
that
Eric Trump allegedly did what have you
there is a difference between the
president and what they do and their
kids can't control what the kids do I
don't condone some of the stuff that
Hunter's done for sure it's not a good
look for the country but it's not like
it's the president doing those things
well if I was a guy who would make short
clips I would take what you just said
and I would take what you said A week
before about guns that if something kid
does the parents should be held
accountable and that contradicts itself
well if you murder somebody what are you
talking about you're doing stuff to 12
year old girls I mean these are minors
well some people would say this is worse
than murder I mean 12 year old girls you
haven't seen what 4chan brought up
yesterday with links on this guy follow
4chan no no I don't either I don't I
don't even know who 4chan was until
yesterday but 4chan they came out and
they said uh you know they found Links
of this guy visiting watching porn with
12 year old girl okay so anyways that
concern no doubt Hunter Biden's a
freaking creep yeah
but to your argument to your point that
you made just a week ago it is you're I
didn't say my point this is your point
to your point you said if the sun does
it parents needs to be held around I
still stand by that comment if you're
gonna if your kid is gonna go out there
and we're talking about uh the latest
thing and uh
but if you're gonna go ahead and take
seven people's lives yeah yeah we're
gonna hold your family accountable so
okay so I'm sticking with them that's
different from what the president don't
tell that story what no no you don't get
look we all contradict that's murder
that's something that you're taking
people's lives
whether your kid does drugs or not
that's a difference I don't say drugs I
didn't say drugs murder is murder
totally get it what about a 50 year old
man having sex with a minor
should go to jail that's it
I don't know should there be an
accountability for the father
no but there should be accountability
for the person that killed uh yes but by
the way mass murder has different uh not
mass murder have a murder period how
about murder period
no I'm talking about mass murder of
innocent people that should we're
conflating two different things we're
you're I see what you're saying here you
do have a point yeah you're basically
saying Adam you're kind of contradictory
accountability should be held to the
parents all I'm saying I'm talking about
accountability for Mass emerging but
we're talking about gun violence so it's
kind of like some please don't kill more
than one person because if you kill two
I'm also going to jail just kill one
something needs to be done I get that
all I'm saying is like look sometimes
I'll give ideas okay and I'll go in a
room and I'll say I want you to be
Devil's Advocate argue my arguments just
debate me right because I want to know
if I have any leaks in my argument okay
you said that last week people thought
about it created a bunch of attention oh
you know what parents should be held
accountable that's the case but okay
that comes a week later if this is true
should he be held accountable for what
his son did he's not a child who's not a
child Hunter's not a child he's not a
child yeah he's not living at home and
then but these people are also not
children that he was talking about last
week that are doing ask you they're also
not 13 14 years old they're also grown
men and men that are that are doing this
arguably grown 17 18 19 20. I think I
think the life experience that takes
place in the 30 years age difference
between the recent shooter and and
Hunter I I I agree I I think that
there's certain accountability
especially if the raising of that child
is so close to that period of time I I
don't think I think Hunter's been Joe's
Bag Man for the past 25 years so I don't
think there's been any upbringing or
raising coming from Joe I think it's a
it's a power Dynamic map Joe's the boss
and Hunter is the worker I think I think
you guys completely missed my point I'm
on the same page with that my history
his point last week was parents should
be held accountable for what the kid
does with mass shooting that's his point
last week that's what I'm saying for me
what Hunter did is what Hunter did I
just said what what Obama's kids do is
what Obama's kids would Ronald Reagan
you do what you got to do you know the
the minor stuff I'm I'm that's a that's
a little that's very sensitive to
appearance and all that stuff that you
go through but to him if he did do what
he did
and all these things that are coming out
with his involvement with politics with
zelinski with Ukraine why you're so
protect every it's a little bit weird
when you're very very protective of
somebody all of a sudden you ever had a
situation where something happened and
one of the guys is all of a sudden
overly protective of a girl you're like
hey bro that's a little um
[Music]
dude you've never talked like that
before how did you all of a sudden
become so protective of Ukraine like did
you do you have some lineage did you do
ancestry.com and they said you're 62
Ukrainian and you're like I don't know
what happened there that you're so so
that's the part where there's a little
bit of speculation and I would like the
professional investigative journalists
to go out there and do some
investigative journalism so I I just
don't think anything is going to happen
like and I was thinking about this if
Trump wins this next president yeah even
if they do an investigation
Joel will be out of he won't be the
president anymore these people just
nothing happens nothing ever happens to
these people the we have the proof you
know it he he's seen a lot we're seeing
like he's smoking crack uh every every
day he just there's another video where
he's weighing like 20 grams of of crack
cocaine with the girl and but nothing's
gonna happen let's be frank about this
this isn't just any father-son Duo right
so Hunter Biden is smoking a lot of
crack right and he just wait out as
Vinnie said 20 grams of crack Joe Biden
wrote the original legislation with
mandatory sentencing laws for crack
cocaine saying if you had five grams
you've got five years mandatory no
probation off at him okay secondly
Hunter Biden has lied on a federal gun
form right he purchased a weapon and
lied on the gun form and then threw the
weapon in the dumpster it's like I I do
think there is a point to where Joe
Biden has to be held accountable for
some of this I I don't I don't disagree
with that part I agree with that part
there needs to be accountability here
but regardless there needs to be
investigative journalism let me give you
my highlight of Jimmy Kimmel I'm not a
camel fan I don't watch Kimmel his humor
is not my kind of humor like Fallon
Moore I like Carson I like Leno I was
more Leno Les Letterman just kind of
like comedy is taste right you probably
like Letterman more than you like Leno I
like Leno you know it's everybody's
taste is different you know what I like
about what camel did it was a week maybe
two weeks you know Kim I'll have within
a two-week span he had Hunter writing
come up and he did the the new book with
crack you know what he was addicted to
how tough it was and all this stuff he
met the scroll at whatever it was at a
rehab place I was like you know what I
appreciate that I was like that's all
you have to do hey here's here's what
I'm going through and they did it and
then camo the next week had the pillow
guy on in that conversation on guess
what I appreciate that I think camel
needs to invite him hey Kimmel he he he
can't he had a he on one of his shows he
threw up a picture a not very flattering
picture of me and he said this guy looks
like he's a tour guide for Loch Ness and
I I was kind of flattered for that but
by the way that's totally fine comedians
make fun of a lot of people and then
they invited back into the show it's his
job somebody wrote that script and he
read it off the teleprompter but but
Kimmel does treat certain guests a
certain way like he was a little softer
with Hunter bite there's no questions
mocks him to his face yeah I'm not the
pillow guy fan whatsoever but that guy
does kind of take it like yeah can I
tell you something as much as I can't
stand Kimmel as much as I can stand
Kimmel that's progress
I agree that's progress to me of course
he's favoring one side and not the other
side I I I I want to sit here and agree
okay I cannot believe like I'm defending
Kim you're like defendant I know but I'm
not playing this game I'm not from Jimmy
Kimmel cut this short clip Up Pat's
defending Jimmy Kimmel oh my gosh but
all I'm saying is to me that's progress
yeah that is progress let the audience
sit there and say I agree I disagree I
do all this all you got to do these days
is just follow what Bill Maher's doing
because when Trump's in the presidency
it's just a [ __ ] show on Trump
especially on the left Trump he sucks
he's an egomaniac he's a narcissist
collusion collusion collusion now that
Biden's in the presidency and countries
kind of going to [ __ ] Hunter Biden
smoking crack John Paul Mack Isaac's
over here hanging out with laptops out
of nowhere all of a sudden people who
lean left have to start saying you know
what this [ __ ] ain't making so much
sense and I gotta find some common sense
you know what's crazy what you just said
that here's what I would do if I was
John Malone I would contact Bill Maher's
agent and I would say through your
contract for 50 million a year 150
million dollar contract for three years
okay I would go after Bill Maher and
bring him to CNN at fire everybody you
got that takes sides who doesn't have
the audacity to you know respect what
like Jake Tapper I think is you know
there's a few people that are you gotta
keep it you got to keep Brian stelter
though he's the backbone there's there's
a few people you can't even mention
their names because they're in Goat
status Brian's in the ghosts I mean
Brian's like yeah Untouchable yeah why
are you saying that they should bring in
Belmont because if John Malone says it's
coward to to do what he's doing and he
wants to go back to investigative
journalism hey go back Bill Marcus Bill
Maher is doing more investigative
journalism as a comedian than any of
your guys in your channel combined so go
offer it at my billmar a 3 or 150
million by the way I don't know if he's
doing investigating I'll take two
percent commission on them I don't know
if Bill Maher's doing
investigative journalism per se I think
he's just calling more than CNN is doing
where it needs to be called out by the
way do you think Bill Maher for the
right price would ever go to CNN I don't
think he would no I don't you know why
let me tell you why there are certain
people who would at for any prize go
anywhere okay there are certain people
that when you've been around for a while
and you find an environment that
supports you leave you alone the team
Works everything's Mission all that
stuff is good they're they're they're
wise enough to know you don't screw up
something like this they're willing to
work when we did I bet you right now if
CNN announced we're giving a I give if
they say three years 200 million dollars
I'm telling you Bill Marshall would turn
it down yeah I agree with you I don't
think he's going to take the money he
had a he had a quote basically saying
these days he gets offered all sorts of
money to go play gigs he gave an example
he was offered a million dollars to fly
to Dubai to do a show one show he goes
I'm good at this point in my life I'm
doing I'm not doing this for the money I
enjoyed my time and doing
hey Bill if you're watching this okay I
try to make you 200 million bucks and he
said no that's your problem not my bill
why don't you get a hold of him okay
send him a message on Snapchat or you
know I don't know on on Instagram or I'm
sure you're pretty easy to get a hold of
with an email I don't do any of that
insta stuff yeah well I hate the
internet I mean I only really got on
Facebook when I opened my business in
2010. well maybe because I value this
kind of social interaction if you if if
you get up you're not my friend it's
probably because I haven't broken bread
with you so well then I would say
probably take a letterhead just like a
regular piece of paper you know a pad
folio whatever you want to call it and
just hand write a letter saying I would
like to invite you on the show okay and
then have him on the show and talk [ __ ]
do what do what you do best and let let
go you're a little bit mainstream to get
you know your main mainstream they're
following your stuff a bunch of item on
board you've had other people on well
you know the only thing for me is just
eyeballs the more people interviewing
him telling the stories the more people
say really let me look into it that's
all it is every picture I see of uh like
Hunter right here he's in a he's in the
top he just loves water and smoking like
he probably dropped the computer inside
this and brought it to you what is that
by the way that clip is what where's
where's that at this is this is from
Hunter this is Hunter on his uh he's
weighing crack with a girl seriously we
gotta watch
look at that 20 grams of crack cocaine
so I don't know if that's two point real
really the the first part
could be not the second part so like
there's if you've noticed over the past
couple weeks there's been a new Trove of
data that's been discovered yeah yeah
because there there was of the 220 gigs
that I recovered there was a 30 gig
iPhone backup that was encrypted
and I believe somebody at the Washington
examiner cracked that encryption so
that's where the the isolation tank
smoking crack drinking beer video came
from a bunch of other interesting things
are on that video uh on that that
encrypted backup
unfortunately whenever something comes
out then somebody else tries to go and
say oh this came off of this and this
came off of that so I I would question
that because I haven't I haven't gone
through the entire
encrypted backup but I have not seen so
by the way I I respect that about you I
mean you could sit here and
completely just throw Hunter under the
bus and but you're basically saying yeah
I don't even know if that's real or not
yeah I would question that because a lot
of people are basically questioning your
credibility right I mean they're calling
you a Russian asset they're saying
legally you know blind you can't see
that well you know you wear the hat to
own the Liberals but uh right fairly
fairly stated and I like it's a good hat
I love the great hat this person for the
record Adam loves your hat very glad you
wore that if you didn't wear the hat I
probably went into the show today so I
respect you for bringing that but a lot
of people have questioned your
credibility but you've been nothing but
forthright and look honest the truth
doesn't pick sides like when I started
going and attacking the individual that
was trying to put out the 450 gigs of
fake data and just trying not to attack
him it was perceived as an attack but
basically put the facts out there here's
the serial number of the laptop anybody
can look that number up through apple
and see that it only had a 250 gig Drive
I recovered 220 gigs of user data so
even it was a full drive there's no way
you can get for it so I'm just trying to
let people aware that there's people out
there that are trying to
dispute this information or muddy the
waters I started getting attacked by the
saying I just I donated to your Gibson
go like a month ago and now you're
turning on us why are you protecting the
bidens why are you doing this and I
started catching Flack from people on
the right and and I'm sorry the truth
doesn't pick sides I love it it really
doesn't would you say that this is the
best thing that's ever happened to you
or the worst thing that's ever happened
to you this whole Fiasco yeah this is
not I did not sign up for this life I
don't want it and I'm not happy but this
is what I have to do because this is
bigger than me you're born on May 2nd
May 3rd May 3rd I was born May 1st your
May 1st yeah so you're May 1st and every
Mario is May 2nd he's May third you guys
should all go hang out on your birthday
and thank you for your father and your
uh grandfather oh my grandfather was
started off uh Army Air Corps in World
War II uh he was a Canadian pilot that
kind of got drafted into the the Army
Air Corps and then um
uh then my father joined the Air Force
and my I have it's the family profession
if I if I was like I'd never served I'm
visually impaired they wouldn't take me
I can apparently see well enough to fly
planes and kill people so you know which
is probably a good thing if you can't
see good
so but thank you uh for acknowledging
the Hat it is a military hat but I have
never served I wanted to get that clear
because I honor those that have served
but I respect
respect so how about we transition into
a complete different Feud that's going
on we mentioned them earlier Twitter
vows legal fight after musk pulls out
of the 44 billion dollar deal this is a
Reuters story Elon Musk said on Friday
he was terminating the 44 billion dollar
deal to buy Twitter because the social
media company had breached multiple
provisions of the merger agreement
Twitter chairman Brett Taylor said on a
micro blogging platform that the board
planned to pursue legal action to
enforce a merger agreement musk's lawyer
said Twitter had failed or refused to
respond to multiple requests for
information on fake or spam accounts on
the platform which is fundamental to the
company's business performance there's
plenty of Precedence uh for deal
negotiate renegotiation in one stance
French retailer Louis Vuitton threatened
to walk away from a deal with Tiffany
and Company the U.S jewelry retailer
agreed to lower the acquisition price
from by 425 million dollars to 15.8
billion dollars so that's kind of what
happened there now you're seeing what's
been the back and forth with you know a
lot of different commentary Trump was at
a rally yesterday speaking uh I'm sure
you guys heard what Trump said I don't
know if you did hear what Trump said but
yesterday Trump is giving a speech and
uh you know uh he says Elan Elon Elon
he's not going to buy Twitter Trump said
after encouraging those in the
attendance to use a competing social
media platform true social and where did
you hear that before from me he's got
himself a mess I've looked at his
contract you know Elon says he's never
voted Republican but I didn't know that
because he told me that he voted for me
so he's another [ __ ] artist anyway
so the moment Elon says this Trump has
to jump in and make a comment so what
are your thoughts about what's going on
with this year Adam well that's uh
you're talking about the Twitter or the
Trump Terror both give me both well I
would hope there's a couple different
things going on number one I would love
to see Elon buy Twitter I think
Twitter's an absolute [ __ ] show the
whole thing that's happening with the
Bots you have you know people
speculating that five percent of the
user bases Bots and then you have Donald
Trump Jr speculating that 50 of the user
base is Bots
um as far as the Trump situation of
course he needs to weigh in and poke fun
at Elon if I'm Trump I'd like to have
Elon as an advocate an ally not an enemy
that's not someone that I want to be
feuding with keep in mind you know as
far as being a [ __ ] artist that's
like the pot calling the kettle black by
the way there's a part of trump that's
in you know there's an ego driven thing
Trump's worth what
two three billion dollars where an Elon
Musk is worth what two three hundred
billion so you know if I'm Trump number
one I'm I'm I want to have Elon on my
side he admitted that he would vote
Republican this time straight up
whether that's the Santos or Trump
remains to be seen but that's not the
type of person you want to be fighting
with furthermore obviously Trump's
always got an angle because what's his
social media Network truth social are
they trying to replace Twitter so of
course there's going to be some feuding
with
as a businessman what what do you think
is going on with him with the deal
pulling is he playing a game no no
listen like you made an offer on a house
and you offered a million bucks okay
during the 60 days closing period uh all
of a sudden uh of I don't know uh a war
happens covet happens you know a massive
disruption happens to the market and
rates Skyrocket whatever percent real
estate valuation drops 20 so that
million dollar house you're buying all
of a sudden it's worth 800 000 you go
back to the buyer and say look I'm not
buying this for a million dollars you're
figuring out a way to get out of the
deal that's what he's trying to do
either I'll buy it for a lot less after
doing the inspection or
uh I'm not gonna buy it and I'm gonna
lose whatever money that I'm putting
sometime when you're buying a house and
you put like this this one building I
bought not this one the other building
that about the Federal Building
there was already a deal in place I went
in with a cash offer and I said look
I'll buy this cash he said show us you
know uh you know if you're really
serious about this so what do you want
me to do he said put a few hundred
thousand dollars in an account that if
we don't close the deal you lose that
money now that's a decision so you see
what happened right there so what I say
okay no problem so I put a few hundred
thousand dollars in an escrow account
sign an agreement that if I don't close
it it's not mine but I bought it cash
and I bought a discounted week later
that I get an offer for six million
dollars on that building but I bought it
for cash right so
in this case if he walks away he pays
that one billion but these guys now want
to sue him and the CEO I don't know if
you guys saw what the CEO of Twitter
said the CEO of Twitter said we're going
to war can you pull this one up we're
going to war with Elon and you know uh
uh CEO of Twitter type in CEO of Twitter
war musk and you'll see an article
that's going to pop up uh there you go
Twitter CEO parag Agarwal willing to go
to war to make Elon musk's deal happen
so go a little lower go a little lower
go a little lower see what everyone's
willing to go to war to make a lot 44
Billion Auto acquisition social media
giant Ahmed reports that the deal could
be in Jeopardy over the sides handling
of spam and Bots after the market closed
must disclose as SCC filing he was
terminating the deal program who assumed
the chief executive job last fall after
the company's co-founder Jack Dorsey
stepped down from the role is reportedly
starting to come out fighting after the
most repeatedly criticized okay so he
has to do that because if he doesn't
show that the investors Agarwal would be
due to receive a paid off 42 million
dollars under current terms of the buy
it as with a handful of Twitter
Executives Agarwal payout will be
triggered by a so-called change in
control clause in their contract which
kicks in after kicks in either of them
is terminated within 12 months of new
ownership assuming to help him of the
company so he has to do that because he
has to be strong in front of his
shareholders and in front of his board
he has to show that fight now is he
gonna win I don't know there's a lot of
people that are hoping that he can force
him to buy Twitter there's a lot of
people that are hoping he ends up buying
Twitter by the way there's a guy named
Professor Galloway Scott Galloway I
don't know if you guys followed this guy
or not
great content he had a she was supposed
to have a show with CNN plus until CNN
plus uh didn't make it with the 300
million dollars CNN they didn't make it
CNN what CNN negative CNN negative
that's a good point well it's actually
not a bad name for a show there we go so
Scott's been uh playing a lot of games
with Elon just kind of driving him you
know saying you were never gonna buy it
you know you were just kind of using
he's trolling Eli hardcore he's
strolling him eventually to the point
where Elon just uh blocked him and then
he came and said here's somebody that's
for freedom of speech why are you
blocking me why are you worried about
what I have to say so there's a lot of
commentary that's going on there with
this uh I just think Elon made an offer
that was 40 to 44 billion and Twitter's
not probably worth
20 to 30 percent less and he's sitting
there saying look I lost 60 billion
dollars on my net worth that was worth
300 billion so if I would have bought it
at 300 billion dollar net worth I've
lost 20 I'd like to buy this 40 whatever
2 billion auto company for 20 less which
is what 34 billion if you want to do
that deal I mean I think that's kind of
what's going on but Twitter wants that
additional 8 billion I may be wrong well
now Twitter's threatening to sue for a
billion bucks no no you're not the
billion they're gonna get no matter what
because that's the billion like when I
said I made that offer on that building
if I close that building or not they're
getting that cash in the escrow so
you're saying that he has to pay that or
that 30 billion is an escrow that that
billion I I assume that billion is going
to go to Twitter no matter what but
Twitter is sitting there saying no no we
lost more than a billion dollars so pbd
here's the question we just got through
with the whole Johnny Depp member heard
you know trial of the decade whatever
what are the chances this goes to court
and how much bigger would this be you
know media wise than the Johnny Depp
Amber Heard which one which one Twitter
versus Elon Musk it's that's not going
to be one 100 of what uh the Amber Heard
situation oh you think Johnny Depp and
Amber hood is going to be bigger than
Elon versus Twitter dude look look at
your podcast when you do your podcast
and there's girl drama guy drama
whatever girl dramas what people want
are you serious Amber Amber Heard is the
goat of drama like yeah you have to even
go to court right have to be there I I
find it very ironic that Amber Heard who
she was with before Johnny Depp it was
freaking Elon Musk yeah that's kind of
not before Johnny Depp wow she was with
Johnny Depp her and Elon dated for a few
it wasn't before what I thought it was
before no no because sir and Johnny have
been around 40 for a while her and Elon
Musk had a fling I think like uh last
year or a couple years so you don't
think that if Elon Musk went to trial
versus Twitter it would be mainstream
news Galore zero but it would not be 1
100 of Johnny Depp and Amber Heard
really are you serious about this
question Elon Musk is arguably the most
famous person in the world do you think
he that people that's the fight I don't
think he'd have to be a dedication trial
it wouldn't be fun or exciting or
dramatic unless he shows up in court and
shits and like and it's not going to be
if January 6 Trump goes to trial now
Amber Heard came over you kind of talk
about eight million people live watching
that one that's a different story okay
so but this one I don't think so this
look there's a big Camp that's hoping
the scans are buying Twitter what camp
are you in I want to see him by Twitter
I want to see what he's saying is when
you get on the the you and I are
protected when Starbucks has a coffee
bean you and I are protected when a
McDonald's has a Burger King you and I
are protected when a 24-hour fitness has
an LA Fitness you and I are protected
when a CNN has a fox you and I are not
protected because there is zero
competitors on social media virtual
governments on the opposite side none
every one of them is one side and all
the other ones that are on the opposite
side they're very very small so in this
case yeah I do want him to buy Twitter
yeah I'd like to see other people also
buy other platforms I'd love to see a
conservative buy New York Times I'd love
to see a fiscally conservative
capitalists by Fortune Magazine I'd like
to see some of those things happening
but uh yes I would like to see this guy
one because I want to see 50 50. that's
how I get clear to the truth because I
want to see debate speaking of Truth
bringing it back to the whole Trump
thing and him you know basically why are
you so active on Truth social and not on
Twitter I can't figure this out it's
just a great place by the way is is
truth social legitimate question is it
active yet are people on it yet yeah no
people are on him on it people are on it
how how is it do you actually use it is
it easy to use
um I I've used getter and Truth again on
more of a defensive strategy when I see
disinformation yeah people start to run
with narratives that are not true then I
will correct correct it uh also it's
it it's self-gratifying because again I
I don't think I I'd had the fortitude uh
to make it through all of this if I
didn't have the direct feedback from the
half of the country that's always
believed me the half of the country
that's been supportive for me giving me
prayers giving me best wishes saying
that they're behind me and and that's it
is good because Facebook tells me how
big of an [ __ ] I am but uh but but
truth you know I get to talk to the
people that really you know they they
want to pray for me let me ask you
political affiliation it's fair to say
that you're right leaning now you're
voting Republican how long have you been
voting Republican for have you ever
voted for a Democrat you know it's funny
because it's in in Delaware uh you
really can't be registered Republican
and vote in any of the primaries or
anything like that so a lot of people
change affiliations I didn't even really
care about doing that the most I've
changed my affiliation is because a girl
told me that she wouldn't date me if I
was a republican how hot was it I'm like
okay well
and how long ago was that
um how'd she murdered me now so this was
probably about six years ago well you
guys are still together oh no no no no
no no
I might as well live near a seminary so
did you vote so you're more worried
about her than Hunter Biden yeah coming
after you
well she knew then oh man well the worst
is and this is in the book
um so while my father and my uncle were
running around trying to knock on
congress's doors to alert them to the uh
the existence of the laptop uh I had a
young lady come into my shop and needed
Mac fixed and then we started chit
chatting and I I have a strict rule of
never chat uh fraternizing with
customers because it's inappropriate a B
I don't need social media to somebody oh
well if you wiggle your whatever you'll
get a better deal you know I don't need
any of that charger 85 or 40. I
I I handled her like a customer you
handled her oh [ __ ] all right
that Ward is a straight up like I
handled you
you handle you Michelle she showed up uh
she showed up at a bar the that I
frequent like the following week yeah
and then we chit-chatted and then uh
then the covet hit and got on lockdown
but we started continuing to have a
online relationship and uh that's when
she informed me that she used to work
for the FBI
[ __ ] and of course I'm just like oh
honey oh honey pot Honeypot gotta be
careful and then uh so we we dated and
the coveted relaxed we we started
getting very serious and uh she came
home this is about mid uh mid-august
yeah uh came home and said um hey I just
got put on this disinformation board and
I'm like oh yeah what are you what are
you going on after because she had been
working on one with coven she does a lot
of Ted stuff and and stuff like that so
I'm very liberal but I'm attracted to
women that want to save the world so you
know so what was the disinformation
board uh to go after all the
disinformation about Hunter Biden and
the Ukraine
is this a joke right now what has
happened I mean I thought so you're
saying that you're dating a woman who's
on the disinformation board about Hunter
buyers and is this a freaking Joker
what's happening I know so I was just I
again I I hadn't told her anything that
was going on Wow but dude she knows
exactly who you are you're an asset she
was my handle she was my she was my
Handler wow yeah I bet she was listen
that world the word handled handle can
go many different ways come on we're
about board here right I don't know well
so what's the status of your
relationship oh no no she she uh and
well
John what are the odds that you meet
some girl online you start dating long
story short you can see them so she's a
disinformation
under Biden oh and she was don't you
think you were set up if you went
through my
social media profile you would probably
figure out that I have a thing for
redheads that are creative and and have
big hearts and want to say the planet so
they put one of those together for me oh
so you know you're admitting that this
was I mean in scientifically put
together in retrospect it's like this
just couldn't this was a perfect time so
when's the wedding oh no no no no she uh
it ended very horribly and then actually
after it ended I figured well I have no
reason now not to
step out from the Shadows I mean I lost
this girl and obviously if if there is
if that was her effort to kind of get a
rise out of me see what I was doing
saying new uh then this is too close and
this needs to end so that's when I went
to uh Rudy giuliani's office so it was
uh it was all happened in that August
uh but yeah it's my lawyer was like yeah
she's a Honeypot but are you enjoying
your 15 minutes of fame women coming
after you getting on podcasts like you
said you never even had Facebook there's
there must be some some part of you
that's like all right cool people know
my name now no the Mac Isaac family is
gonna have a great legacy now we had one
and I was quite happy turning screws in
a Backwater shop in in Wilmington this
is not the life that I want at all I'm
not comfortable with it if I come across
as nervous and uncomfortable there's a
reason for that I like helping people I
like fixing Max it's what I did for a
quarter of a century now I'm an author
or now I'm on podcast doing things that
I'm not comfortable doing talking about
things that I wish never happened and I
didn't sign up for it but this is my job
now and I have a responsibility I feel
the sincerity I totally feel the
sincerely I feel the sincerity so uh can
you do text to the three redheaded girls
don't work
they're not outside
I don't only have sex with that hat on
hold
on
that's it I am so afraid of being me too
I don't go out I don't go online I don't
chat I don't even talk to girls that
reach out to me because you are it's a
no you know it's a it my life's a bit of
a [ __ ] show uh it's it's a bit of a
dumpster fire the FBI is rated everybody
else who's touched that drive I'm sure
that they're just trying to figure out
how much crap I actually have because
they're gonna need a 24-foot box truck
to empty out my house with technology so
you know and and so this is these are
all things that aren't really
necessarily marketable when you're
pursuing a relationship so yeah I that's
that's so far out of my mind right now
plus I'm so scared if I even look at a
girl she'll be like oh he did this you
know me too you gotta document
everything listen the best comment of
the day by uh kov 12x12x which I think
his name is uh uh Paul and he's a member
he said CNN will only give straight out
straightened out when they hire a man
like no hands Carl 100
so this other person's zero latency
manifestation what role if any have
Global intelligence agencies
historically played in perpetrating
elections fraud okay worldwide and
another one here a smeldy butler the
third what a name Smedley Butler III so
wait if organizations admitted the
laptop was real could you not take legal
action they spent months accusing you of
colluding With the Enemy treason ain't
no small uh time accusation yep and
that's why again back in April I didn't
think I'd have this opportunity but back
in April my my lawyer texted me he's
like Merry Christmas
I was like what why are you are you okay
and he said no Joe Flynn and the America
project wanted to fund our lawsuits
because we we had them to go but after
Twitter I had to go from offensive to
defensive because you know that's a big
Bill and I don't want to I had to go
from going to profit to bankruptcy it
was not kind of turned me off to the
whole legal thing anyway because it was
like the expectation of getting Justice
and then now I'm punished for what I did
in the court of law but if the American
project wants to step up then we had
Adam Schiff ready to go he was top on my
list CNN Politico The Daily Beast just
bowed out they saw the storm is coming
and uh which is they just called me a
thief for the most part they didn't
really I wanna I wanna go after that
specific Narrative of who said that this
was Russian disinformation and the
people that peddled that narrative
because that narrative to be honest was
a campaign
promise it was it was being touted by
the uh the Biden campaign as the
justification for not having to touch
the laptop with the 10-foot pole so
anybody that talked about that laptop
being Russian and helped Aid that
narrative is on my list is he on okay so
we got a special guest here can you hear
us
okay fantastic can you do me if everyone
put the picture of uh him if you have
that to we have a special guest here
with us today but before you find out
who our special guest is do you have the
picture or no with him holding the first
cell phone or no okay you should put the
picture Our Guest right now if you're
using a cell phone
if you're using a smartphone if you're
using anything that is mobile when it
comes onto phones
blame it on this man because he is the
inventor of the first cell phone who
just the other day he was being
interviewed about you know inventing the
new cell phone a comment was made about
how much people are spending time on
smartphones and he had an opinion I
think I think it's good for everybody
else to hear as well first of all hey
you know thank you I don't know if we
say thank you or you know why did you
invest this cell phone but thank you for
inventing this great technology that
allows us to stay connected with each
other
foreign
because uh
the uh this story that the BBC put out
yeah kind of implied that I thought the
cell phone was ever useful and of course
that's certainly wrong I don't think
first of all the cell phone is being
used by more people than any other
invention in history and I think for the
most part that it's a positive that it's
improved people's lives except that
there are some people that just get
carried away and this lady in the BBC
interview said that she spends five
hours a day on her cell phone which
doesn't make any sense to me at all and
my response was get a life
now is it fair to say that you uh don't
spend five hours on your smartphone with
you know going on Facebook Instagram
Snapchat
maybe I don't know maybe you're
extremely active on Tick Tock and you
have a massive follow-on is your
smartphone actively being used by you or
no you don't spend five hours on your
phone
I no I do not spend five hours on my
phone you know if my view of technology
is that technology uh makes sense only
if it improves your life
and so I I use my phone for research and
anytime I have an issue that I don't
understand uh of course I'll look it up
on my cell phone I don't do social media
mostly because it's a Time waster I
think social media is very important in
the sense that it brings people together
but I the cell phone's still a very new
uh Gadget it's only been around in the
Forum that we have it today for 10 or 15
years people are still learning about it
and I think that the social media is a
form of learning but not very efficient
you know I'm a I'm an engineer Patrick I
believe in efficiency and I think we're
still learning Martin what kind of phone
do you use right now I'm curious are you
I'm so curious to know what you use if
you pull out one of those big phones
that you invented yourself I would be so
impressed
I've always tried to use the latest
phone that's available and what's
happened now is that there's really not
very much difference uh and I do use an
iPhone I've tried the faulting phones I
know they don't really do much for me
and I think that the existing phone
concept is is uh way behind the times
you know in the coming years and we're
going to see the phone much more
personalized and much more useful
distributed around your body instead of
of being this awesome thing that we hold
up to Earth really you think that you're
in this position it doesn't make any
sense at all so uh as I said before
we're still in early times of the cell
phone we're still learning so you think
we're going into a phase where we're not
going to be having a phone in our
pockets in our hands it's just gonna be
you know uh handless not even Wireless
you're just not going to have to use
anything with it you're just gonna say
hey uh you know talk to a phone and it's
going to make a phone call to somebody
with nothing to hang on to
absolutely the phone as you refer to it
is ultimately going to be embedded under
your skin uh maybe behind your ear wow
yeah it's kind of a amusing that you
call it a phone because very few people
use the phone as a telephone are you
kind of throwing your uh uh you know are
you trying to make a comeback like are
you like setting this up for a comeback
that you have a phone you're developing
and building that we don't know about as
an engineer
no no no no I'm a husband uh in Federal
I still think of a lot of ideas but
other people are going to have to invent
that but you know the the big deal about
the what we call the phone is it
connects you and it connects you in a
whole bunch of different ways and so
this thing that we call this one's going
to be used as an educational tool yeah I
think every student has to have if a
device that he can or she can access the
internet 24 7. that's crucial I think
this the future cell phone is a
healthcare device it can measure
everything on your body it can head off
diseases before they happen and so uh I
think the what we call a cell phone is
going to eliminate disease someday
let me ask you for somebody that you
know this is your space you've been
following this for all these years does
it concern you that we're going to be
putting chips in our bodies like if it
goes that Direct would that be would you
fight it or would you say no I'm totally
fine with putting a chip on my body
well
I hate to say this Patrick but I I have
two implanted hips and that served me
very well so putting a chip in my body
as well with a no-brainer
I welcome it hey Martin do you get a my
name is Vincent uh very nice to meet you
do you get a royalty for every cell
phone sold since you came over here I
wish I got a penny for every cell oh my
God I mean he started it oh my God that
would be what if he got a penny would be
a whole different story Martin thank you
so much for giving us a few minutes of
your time and I think that there's about
eight billion people in the world who
are thankful for you for that invention
you made appreciate you thank you
thank you so much Patrick because you'd
like to be here have a great day bye
how awesome is that right no seriously
just Innovation like you think about
those uh uh uh phones back in the days
the break that you would hang on like
Miami Vice Don Johnson and he's driving
the car yeah what do you call that phone
that he's got in his hand what would you
call that that's a brick it's a brick I
would call that the Zack Morris phone oh
Save By The Bell
the one problem the one problem I have
with the idea of a chip being embedded
in that and your body becomes the phone
or that idea is how is that a process
we're gonna have to get done every year
when they keep these companies keep
coming out with new phones
the battery I mean faster chips you got
to just go to Apple you're like can you
update yeah can you remove my old chip
put a new chip is that what he actually
said that cell phones are gonna be
implanted in our body that is everyone
is okay with that no what what do you
mean I'm not bro if you're if you're
watching this how many of you if you
don't mind put a thumbs up if you're
like totally fine with a champion put in
my body I got other things put into my
body of course say never in a million
years would I put a chip in my body not
to be religious but they said it in the
Bible how long the mark of the bees go
I'm not putting nothing inside mark of
the beast I'm not putting nothing inside
of me sorry how many people do you think
would be okay with that
uh I think people above a certain age
are gonna be less uh open to the idea of
doing that and I think people who are
teen 20s 30s they're going to be more
open to the idea when Facebook first
came out and somebody explained to you
to Facebook the first time do you
remember the first time somebody
explained to Facebook yeah like how did
they explain it they said it's what you
go on this website and you post your
pictures and people can't see it they're
like I don't want to post my pictures
and then we're on Facebook Tick Tock
Twitter all these other things that
you're doing nowadays so who knows if if
the majority do it by the way most
people are saying no right now of course
take a screenshot of you saying no and
see if you would say no 15 years from
now I'm curious see if the same people
that are saying no today would say no 15
years from now Okay Tyler that includes
you by the way okay do you think Hunter
Biden would be okay with that if Hunter
Biden had a chip in his body he would
have never lost his laptop exactly
period
I don't know I don't I don't think he's
so I've noticed you don't answer you
don't answer things that um you don't
know the answer to or you don't you
don't speculate I don't like to respect
well I I've noticed that about I worked
in the service industry for 25 years at
Apple they taught us you know don't ever
speculate the best way to gain a
customer's trust get their confidence
because that's the most important part
of the repair is letting the customer
know that you're trustworthy you're able
to communicate their problem and explain
a solution set an expectation and then
achieve it and speculating has no place
in in the service industry I mean sure
there's you can well it could be this it
could be this it could be this as long
as you're right and you can back it up
then you're fine but until then it's
best not to speculate well when you when
you're podcasting career blows up you're
gonna have to start speculating because
that's all we do this you don't want to
[ __ ] did you guys see what's going on
with Canada are you following the story
what's going on in Canada so yesterday I
just put a tweet out and I said there's
a bunch of guys in Canada that are
sending me stuff if you want to go to
the story
it is page nine okay if you want to go
to page nine I don't even know if I have
page nine this it says oh page six okay
here we go so
um
there you go Rogers network resuming
after major outage hits millions of
Canadians this is a reuter story July 9
two days ago Roger selling communication
said his network was beginning to
recover late on Friday after 19 hours
service outage at one of Canada's
biggest Telecom operations shut banking
transport and government access for
Millions drawn outrage from customers
and adding to criticism over its
industry dominance nearly every facet of
life has been disrupted with the outage
affecting internet access cell phones
landline phone communication connections
some callers could not reach Emergency
Services via 911 calls Canadians crowded
over crowded into cafes and public
libraries that still had internet access
and hovered outside hotels to catch a
signal pretty wild for this to happen 19
hours when I read it I almost thought it
was a movie and I'm like no I message
people is this really happening Yep this
is exactly what's going on in Canada
right now
so just one network Rogers is it that's
all they have Tyler Rogers network is
that their main Network that they have
I'm pretty sure that I've never even
heard of another one except so lady sent
me a message here's what she said
private message she said saw your Tweet
Canada I think you'll find people here
who are afraid to speak up publicly it's
very scary we're working on an exit
strategy to get assets and family out of
the country thank you for posing this
question hopefully people will start
talking also love your work especially
your content webinar preparing for
recession but I definitely love Adam the
most so here you go that I added at the
end I think appreciate that okay here we
go with about 10 million Wireless
subscribers and 2.25 retail and
subscriber Rogers is the top provider in
Ontario Canada's most populous Province
and home to its biggest Toronto uh City
Toronto Rogers BC and tell us control 90
of the market share okay so this is not
just a small company that this is
happening to no and I've I've heard
people are pretty upset with the
monopolization of that they have I mean
the outsized market share that they
control is that 90 they control ninety
percent of the market full-on Monopoly
what point is it become a monopoly 40th
that's exactly uh
uh there's different numbers uh that you
hear about 46 64 but there's different
numbers but the 90 years
and we you messaged this yesterday in
Instagram and uh Raul came back with a
pretty interesting point that this is
what remember Dr Peter pry talked about
if you had uh um a uh not a solar flare
but brought the network down it would be
something equivalent to this shutting
down the banking systems television
phone lines everything would shut down
it's pretty interesting I'm gonna show
you something uh Tyler I'm gonna give
this to you put this up on the big
screen so people can see it uh this is a
shout out to the prime minister of uh uh
Canada he's so he was walking in Canada
and people were shouting at him and it
was not friendly because when I posted
this a bunch of people from Canada sent
me a bunch of tweets look at this data
here okay
um debt from uh uh pretrude though all
the prime ministers combined since 1867
630 billion dollars in debt just under
Trudeau 662 billion dollars in debt
that's a big number right there I mean
Trudeau must be very competitive to put
a number like that okay you know in and
by the way if you if you keep doing that
to a country that doesn't have the
biggest GDP in the world 666 662 in
America is what
nothing but 662 for a Canada that's a
lot of money right there well now it's
nothing I remember during 2008 the
recession when we were going to bail out
whoever we were bailing out we were it
was still in the billions it was still
like 900 something billion now we don't
bat an eye when we're cutting checks for
trillion we printed what five trillion
dollars since the pandemic so we're in
the trillions now they're still working
with billions they've got some catching
up to do by the way
you must have some strong I mean we've
we've sat down with Jordan Peterson here
Canadian yeah this was during the you
know in the truckers Revolt that they
were doing
um in Ontario we've had uh Dr gadsat
here recently basically saying I've gone
into business with the Canadian
government they take 60 of my earnings I
run into Canadians all the time I had a
couple uh saw a couple of buddies uh
that I ran into in Miami this weekend
basically saying I gotta get the hell
out of this god-forsaken country what
the hell is going on in Canada is it
just becomes so far extreme socialism is
it is it Trudeau is just an
authoritarian disguised as a nice guy
what do you think is happening in Canada
you're asking him or as he knew I mean
that's exactly what happens when you
give somebody too much power
and their motives are not positive
motives the results are this
you know what's taking place in Canada
and the reality of it is a lot of people
that were messaging me they were all
saying the same thing we're trying to
figure out a way to leave here with our
assets okay when we left Iran this is
the story that most people don't hear
about maybe you have stories like this
as well a lot of people when they left
Iran
the the people that left
pre-shaw's Revolution they left with
their money
but the people that left post Shaw's
Revolution and how many came in they
couldn't leave with their money so the
money was left so if you'd like let's
just say you sold the property in Iran
and you wanted to bring your money to
the state that wasn't easy to do so
imagine you're living in Canada you got
a million bucks there you got a half a
million you've been working 40 years and
you got a half a million bucks you got a
million dollars saved you're trying to
come to the States you know you want to
take that out I don't know if that's the
case but if they're going in this
direction of doing things like this it's
a scary sight look again it goes back to
the following
don't just vote for somebody because
they're attractive and they speak well
and their father was a former PM whose
mom had a fling with allegedly Fidel
Castro with Fidel Castro which he looks
just Jordan Peterson shot that down well
he can't shut it down because he's from
Toronto he doesn't want his funds to be
protected before he leaves but look at
that right there I mean that's that's
way too close wait 24 even said it that
was exactly where I was headed what to
victory yeah so look you know if you're
you what's the difference between a
capitalist and a socialist when it comes
down to their philosophy speaking
publicly what is the difference between
a capitalist and a socialist when it
comes down to telling the world publicly
what's the difference
the Socialist says I'll do everything
for you the capitalist says no thank you
I'll do it myself the capitalist is very
comfortable telling the world he's a
capitalist the Socialist keeps it a
secret until he has enough control to
say all along I was about socialism
there's a video that a guy sent me
yesterday I'm going to send to you Tyler
to play this of Maxine Waters did you
see that video or no so this is from
2008 when the market crash takes place
which by the way you're going to see
this happening in America today Tyler
I'm texting it to you to put it up just
show the text of what I just sent you so
oh wait there's a hearing and Maxine
Waters is talking to the CEO of shell
and a CEO of shell is saying look if you
keep doing what you're doing
five dollar gas prices are going to be a
thing of the past this is when oh wait
14 years ago look at Maxine Waters
response just put the audio uh uh yeah
put the audio up and just play from the
beginning watch this folks to the
American people because of the inaction
of the United States Congress ever
increasing prices unless the demand
comes down and the five dollars will
look like a very low price in the years
to come if we are prohibited from
finding new reserves new opportunities
to increase supplies and guess what this
liberal would be all about this liberal
will be all about socializing uh
would be about
basically taking over
and the government running all of your
companies to the Americans people
because you couldn't even know
so all I'm saying to you is folks
speculation let's speculate okay that's
I can speculate you don't have to
speculate let me do the speculation you
stick to the redhead it's I'm going to
stick to the speculation you ready
here's some speculation okay if
there was a strategy
with oil prices to nationalize it what
would you do first first you create
policies like shutting down the what the
Keystone Pipeline that we can control
gas prices and shut them down first day
one which they did two you actually
allow gas prices to increase to hurt who
low and middle income families three you
blame who shell Exxon Mobil everybody
four you come and you say what this is
why oil should be something that's
nationalized and managed by who the
government if that's your strategy
that's the proper four-step sequence to
nationalize oil okay and folks you do
not want
that industry to be nationalized as much
as you know they're thinking we're going
to go green we did a video on Eevee
versus uh uh gas the the the price paid
to go 100 EV it's going to be on the
backs of a lot of workers in uh what is
that one place in Africa Congo
Democratic Congo that's got what 60 of
the Cobalt or some 64 the world's Cobalt
that China bought the land to this place
yeah and all these people that are
working so this is not going to be an
overnight thing you use oil more than
you think we do but the marketing and
the way the story is telling being told
it's different so socialize you just saw
Maxine Waters from California she tried
to hold it back couldn't do it slipped
up she couldn't do it in no way it
slipped up so anyways uh I wanted to
show that video too because I want all
of you guys to go start your week on a
good note with a lot of positivity a lot
of excitement can I make one crazy
prediction let's go can I make one crazy
prediction so I I just shot a the real
estate video okay at the house
and we had our research team pull up a
bunch of data because I'm talking to a
lot of real Realtors loan officers and
mortgage brokers title escrow a lot of
these guys
and the video that was made when we
called that Dave Ramsey I cannot believe
you're saying this and I hope I would
say well you know no problem you don't
have to listen to I'm just telling you
it's what we did can I tell you crazy
stat
UE q1 this year over q1 last year
what percentage you think foreclosures
in America have increased q1 this year
over q1 last year 10 percent
how much you think foreclosures have
increased q1 of this year over q1 of
last year 15 what would you say just
guess that's a lot by the way 20 I don't
know pick the number from from last year
last year q1 versus this year q1 how
much you think by the way q1 the rates
were still okay the rates have gone up
the last two months is what's happened
that's been kind of scary how much you
think an increase foreclosures I'll say
20 what are you gonna say
how about 700 what q1 23 000
foreclosures last year we had around
twenty five hundred to three thousand
foreclosures you hear what I just said
and by the way it hasn't even started
yet and it's 700 foreclosures q1 uh the
data we got on what buyers are doing
what investors are doing what escrow
people are doing what loan officers
don't do I mean I'm that video is going
to be coming out here in the next week I
think we're going to be doing a live
real estate webinar I think it's going
to be next Tuesday night stay tuned the
details will be made this will be packed
everybody will be on this webinar when
this goes on next Tuesday here's a crazy
prediction for you people don't want to
hear it I think 30-year fixed mortgage
rates will eventually get to 10 in the
next six 12 18 months okay
we said gas price is 10 bucks that's one
side okay that's becoming more and more
possible that it could happen California
there's a 70 prices over there interest
rates 30 are fixed don't be surprised if
they crack 10 now all this stuff said
being said and done you're gonna see a
lot of mess happening my biggest
suggestion to you I'm telling you don't
overspend save your cash go make income
have a secondary income set that money
aside there's going to be a lot of
opportunities and there's unfortunately
going to be some people that are going
to be asking their you know hey can I
get this shop can I get that job who had
a few hundred thousand dollars in
Bitcoin and cryptocurrency they're going
to go through that this is going to be a
very strange in X6 12 18 24. and by the
way for the people that are like that's
crazy he doesn't know what he's talking
about okay with that just if you don't
study history you're doing to repeat it
this is exactly what happened in the
late 70s early 80s under our friend your
friend Jimmy Carter okay but by the way
can you can you do me a favor can you do
me a favor go go on go on my Twitter
account go on my Twitter account and
matter of fact let me see if I can send
this to you go on my Twitter account go
on Twitter and go up go up go up go up
go up Go Play that video Play that video
right above our Maxine Waters video Just
Play that video go pause it first if you
can pause it first make it bigger make
the screen bigger yeah audio and look at
the date what's the date 2018. that's
three and a half years ago I already I
already knew it was prior to 2020
because you had the shaved head this is
before you started rocking the great
hair yes that was so much easier so
easier isn't it watch this watch this
two things something's gonna happen the
next five years and the people that are
going to make massive wealth are the
ones that save cash so I'm a cash guy
not not always I'm a cash guy pre-crisis
you're a cash guy pre-christ which is
which is now which is now which is now
so right now is a great time to have a
lot of cash here's the rule of zero the
rule of zero this is how this is gonna
be you are very greedy because it sounds
easy saying it but let me
explained in 2008 took place a lot of
people lost money you know they were
talking about the 401ks now the 201 care
I had clients I would go look at their
statement they would say I only have 380
000 I'm like that's not bad for you it
says well this used to be 790 000 wow
that's a pretty bad thing right there
and they're 64 years old what do you
tell this person they got to work for
another seven more years they were
planning on retiring for one year but
because they were not fully ready and
they did not take advantage to power
zero because in 2008 Market tank 38 in
2008 if you did zero percent in 2008
that really means you did plus 38
compared to what the market did so you
you have to also be paying attention to
the offense you're playing you got to be
playing offense as well of course if you
want to create wealth offense often soft
and softens offense but you got to have
a certain strategy on how you can take
advantage of rule of zero so when it
does happen you have more that's sitting
for you to say this is my next
opportunity to go in because you paid
attention to the room okay pause right
there so we've been seeing this for a
while from bytainment so if you've been
following the content this has been the
message for five years that this season
is eventually going to come in the
history of America since uh Inception
you know how many recessions we've had
since 1850 and how many recessions we've
had you know what the number is 44. it
breaks down to be what a recession every
five to ten years when's the last time
we had a recession was oh wait we
haven't had one for 14 years so that's
the data recession is very sad because
the quick forget about cope was not
recession covet was just manufactured we
haven't had a recession in 14 years
we're overdue for recession don't sit
there being naive so it'll never happen
you being negative I'm just telling you
it's a cycle all okay it's a cycle
that's coming anyways great podcast
um uh we appreciate you for uh Having
the courage to come out and talk to us 5
000 of them out yeah I mean there's a
lot of people wait Matt Isaac in the
House John Paul with his act in the
house uh guys do me a favor go on are
you on Twitter or you're not on that's
right you're on the other side go go ask
go tweet at billmar and just tell them
hey can you please have John Paul Mack
Isaac on your show go and tweet CNN and
say hey today John Paul uh Mac Isaac was
on uh uh PVD podcast can you please
invite him to CNN host that you respect
go ask them why don't you bring in
investigate do some investigative
journalism why are you not the people
that you like the most why don't you
tell them I would like you to see how
you're going to interview John Paul Mac
Isaac different than they did on pbd
podcast but we need more of this
conversation being had having said that
I think you got a book coming on
November 22nd of 2022. hopefully sooner
hopefully sooner when it does uh
audience will be able to find it but and
this is the website this is the Gibson
go all of it will be in the description
what's the website called so in case on
the podcast that's uh give send go so
it's like the Christian GoFundMe and
they're the gifts and go and just build
back Mac Isaac well you know kind of a
play on build back better I love that
I'd love to get some usefulness out of
that I love that part so I I do want to
say thank you to everybody that has
contributed because but bankruptcy no
longer looks like my only option so I'm
grateful for that that has taken a
weight off my shoulders so now I can
focus in on trying to hold these people
accountable getting to Discovery and and
making sure that our next election we
don't have this collusion that we did
the last time well listen we appreciate
your uh sincerity and we appreciate you
being willing to come and talk about it
gank have a great day we're going to do
this again on Thursday uh vacation
comedy came out with a new clip if you
haven't seen it go meet uh Carl Carl No
Hands car oh my God my dad watch it was
cracking up what do you got going on
this week some interesting ladies won't
be here from the Exotica conference yes
oh my God yeah is there a name that you
can drop or not we have Alexis Texas
coming through and some of her lady
friends audience you're going in we're
going to be talking about what women are
doing with their money these days that's
all types of women okay all right that's
good well there's a redhead there you
may you may have John no invite you back
for the record gen sake ruined oh
all right so this was back then this is
you know this was pre-section yeah have
a good day everybody take care bye-bye
cheers that